bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous avec ça une avanie qui
a donc souhaité rentrer en russie
sachant qu'il se ferait arrêter
quels objectifs poursuite il selon vous
et bien en effet il va être sur le
terrain
il veut agir sur l'activité entre
politique russe et puis navalni gêne il
a 44 ans je pense qu'il sera tj à long
terme sa stratégie à long terme c'est en
effet de d'augmenter sa notoriété en
russie actuellement une certaine
notoriété à moscou il avait d'ailleurs
surpris tout le monde en 2013 lorsqu'il
avait fait 27 % des voix à l'élection
municipale pour l'élection du maire et
dans les grandes villes il a une
certaine notoriété mais globalement en
russie on trouve je crois d'après les
sondages 1 pour 1 % des russes qui
savent exactement qui il est et qui
approuve plus ou moins sa démarche
donc je pense qu'il a le temps alors il
va agir naturellement lors des
différentes échéances politiques comme
il l'a déjà fait il a déjà fait pour les
essais an des élections régionales en
appelant les électeurs à voter pour le
candidat le mieux placé mais contre le
candidat de russie unie et il fera
probablement la même chose pour les
élections législatives du mois de
septembre prochain
mais encore une fois il a le temps donc
il se positionne pour plus tard pensant
que il y aura bien un jour finalement où
il y aura une relève politique et où la
classe politique est actuellement au
pouvoir
cédera la place à une génération plus
jeune alors que signifie une détention
d'une durée de quatre semaines pour lui
voilà je crois que c'est le tarif
puisque en réalité il y avait en effet
une demande de l'administration qui est
chargé de l'exécution des peines et
cette demande reprocher à monsieur
navalni de ne pas avoir pointé à un
commissariat de moscou le 30 novembre
dernier pour tout le monde savait qu'il
était en train de se faire soigner à
là et qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être dans
ce commissariat vous trouvez ça fait
rien l'administration chargée de la
gestion des peines a demandé au juge de
prononcer cette peine de quatre semaines
de prison en attendant qu'un juge statue
au fond je crois que c'est le début du à
d'un nouveau d'une nouvelle période de
harcèlement judiciaire à l'égard de
navalni il est avocat donc il connaît ça
depuis depuis longtemps et il joue avec
d'ailleurs ses propres avocats
avec la législation russe pour alterner
les périodes disons de liberté sous
surveillance et les périodes de ses
jours en prison
plusieurs pays condamnant cette
arrestation quelles peuvent être les
conséquences au niveau international oui
alors bien sûr la chine ne condamne pas
et d'une manière générale l'ensemble des
pays d'asie ne se prononce pas les pays
d'afrique non plus tous considèrent que
ceci est une affaire purement intérieure
à la russie en revanche les occidentaux
ont fait d'alexei navalni une sorte de
symbole
une sorte de symbole de l'opposition
politique en russie
il a en effet un abord très très
médiatique et il a réussi à convaincre
les occidentaux qu'il était le véritable
représentant de l'opposition systémique
en russie et par conséquent vient les
pays européens ont condamné on demandait
sa libération immédiate
les etats unis également et ce procès
sujet sera sans doute évoqué lors du
conseil européen du 21 janvier donc très
prochainement en visioconférence et
certains pays peut-être demanderont de
nouvelles sanctions il n'est pas sûr que
il y est
un consensus pour décider de nouvelles
sanctions
certaines sanctions avaient déjà été
votée et après tout la détention qui a
été infligé à monsieur navalni nez
j'allais dire n'est que de quatre
semaines c'est déjà beaucoup mais je
pense que l'union européenne va plutôt
pesé pour qu'ils soient libérés le plus
tôt possible
quel avenir selon vous pour alexeï
navalni en russie comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
joue à long terme et la première
question c'est de savoir s'il va gagner
son pari le pari qu'il l'a fait en
revenant hier à moscou à savoir de
gagner en notoriété et de gagner
finalement dans l'opinion publique
c'est loin d'être certain parce que en
effet elle est certainement très
populaire chez les gens qui naviguent
sur les réseaux sociaux dans les grandes
villes mais lee est à peu près inconnu
ailleurs en russie est d'une autre un
autre un autre aspect c'est que
aujourd'hui la population russe est
surtout préoccupé par la dégradation de
la situation économique de la situation
sociale et la situation sanitaire
or sur ces projets de fond monsieur la
vanille ne s'exprime pas merci et qu'il
attend les prochaines élections pour
pouvoir agir ou merci claude avalanche
rêvant d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse